despite appearing to be nothing more
than a cute little kitty at this
merciless creature is one of the most
powerful entities in Captain Marvel and
potentially the entire MCU don't believe
us ask Nick Fury here's everything you
need to know about the cats in Captain
Marvel spoilers ahead in the comics the
idea of Carole having a loyal pet kitty
predates the occasion of her officially
taking the mantle of Captain Marvel with
a cat making his first appearance in
2006 s giant-sized Miss Marvel issue 1
but much like in the movie in which it
takes up until the 3rd act for the other
Alien Shooter drop the cat spent years
in the comics being seen as just a cat
it only reached its full fearsome
potential as an alien Fleur kin drawing
the space set 2014 run of Captain Marvel
in the comics Carole first meets a cat
in an imagined alternate dimension
conjured up by Scarlet Witch during the
House of M storyline but is fortunate
enough to see the creature crossed back
over into her reality with her when the
illusion comes to an end in the movies
though the cat is introduces a companion
of annette bening marvel another alien
in disguise hiding out on earth though
Captain Marvel's cat has only appeared
in one movie so far it's already
responsible for one of the most
consequential actions and the entire
Marvel Cinematic Universe scratching out
Nick Fury's eye ever since he was
introduced in a surprise post-credits
coda to 2008 iron man samuel l.jackson
'he's Nick Fury has won a patch over his
left eye implying a fairly badass
backstory in Captain America the Winter
Soldier of fury hinted at what happened
now more than 10 years after being
introduced in the movies we finally know
the origins of Nick Fury's signature
injury the fleur kin dinner well I lost
my eye to an alien is a pretty cool
story to tell over drinks it loses a
little bit of that cool factor when the
alien in question looks like a typical
house cat so fury has been letting
rumours take hold and embracing the myth
making around his lost IE ever since in
the Captain Marvel movie Carole's cat is
pegged as a fleur kin by Talos a Skrull
who reacts to the creatures present of
what turns out to be well justified fear
but in the comics the Castro identity
was first noticed by another deceptively
cute character Rocket Raccoon of
guardians of the galaxy fame when rocket
first meets Carole's cats he immediately
sets out trying to engage it
combats hoping to kill it before it gets
the chance to kill him despite Carroll's
protests rocket raves about the monsters
fearsome powers including a carnivorous
mouthful of hellish tentacles they were
first he sounds paranoid about the
creatures true nature he's eventually
proven right when the Fleur can quietly
laze dozens of eggs tipping Carol after
fuzzy friends curiously alien nature
Captain Marvel uses its 90s setting as
an excuse for an in-universe prequel
throwback centering the action on the
MCU phase ones tesseract aka the magical
blue cube that houses the blue space
stone in the movies that this
consequential cube spent time apparently
being protected by the belly of the
flock in sitting and digested in his
terrifying stomach until the choice was
made to vomit it up on a desk at shield
headquarters at some undisclosed later
time as shown during Captain Marvel's
second and credits scene as the comics
made clear the belly of the Fleur King
isn't just an usually stretchy it's
actually its own pocket dimension
capable of containing unknown multitudes
of matter organic or otherwise as though
wonder people are so scared of the thing
it doesn't just swallow people whole it
completely removes them from their own
reality sending them off to world's
unknown despite being in a universe
where it's been firmly established the
animals and plants can talk the Fleur
Canon Captain Marvel generally keeps his
lips sealed only opening its mouth to
hilariously devour entire hallways worth
of crease soldiers among other untold
atrocities as a result so there's not a
lot of courage sir to this character at
least not that we get to see what does
the Fleur can want in both the comics on
the movies the Fleur can is generally
used as a joke onto itself created for
what seems like the sole purpose of
setting up the punty line no one steals
my flirting cards it also serves as a
vehicle for cute pop-culture references
in the comic run in which its backstory
as a fearsome alien is introduced the
cat is known as chewy after the
well-known Star Wars character bakka
all right well you're gonna be the
nickname cuz I ain't saying that every
time this makes sense considering the
story takes place while Carol is in
space the movie augments this connecting
the cat to the Air Force Base on which
Carol the marvel both work and giving it
the name of Grusin reference to the 80s
classic aerial combat movie Top Gun most
definitely a favorite film for movie
eights pilot Carol though a trip through
Blockbuster Video seems to indicate she
might want to give the right stuff a try
the next time she's back on Earth check
out one of our newest videos right here
plus even more looper videos about your
favorite MCU characters are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]